hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to room smash from the
creators of solar smash except on a
smaller scale we're going to destroy
everything in sight
except then we blew up a whole planet
and killed everybody on the planet but
now we're going to blow up a room and
hopefully not kill anybody in the room
it's a safer alternative probably so the
principle is probably much the same
you blow [ __ ] up uh
i don't know yet how would i know i
haven't even played it
okay so we've got buttons here
okay holding off i know that this is
just going to end up blowing things up
right away so let's
not do that just yet i want to explore
the options
first plant i like plant
is that like a diamond or something
it's a rock sorry
it's dude it's just a rock
this is the most mild destruction anyone
has ever done
okay sorry
right in the dummy dick okay
[Music]
okay well surprisingly the rocks are
doing a bit of damage
that seems like something precarious
[Music]
whoa
well i didn't know that that was a thing
what is this
oh that's much different than
that's much different than a rock you
okay buddy
you all right what am i aiming my
earthquake
okay so that's boring what is this oh
no oh god oh no
you okay is that your leg over there oh
god it's your arm
i don't know why i'm always shocked
whenever i manage to kill things
good lord slow-mo
yeah you know this is yeah good luck
getting the first aid [ __ ]
have fun first aiding in space douche
nozzle
all right whatever this is very
[Music]
[Music]
concerning
okay yes very destructive very good very
very very fine let's get another area
here
hey what's up gang oh rough day
work my dude oh man that's a shame
hey that's okay i'm just here to play a
little target practice
all right let's do this one didn't
notice the thing this guy's a
professional
not a thing this guy's good
see if i can knock the bottle right out
of this guy's hand
[Music]
you okay buddy you're all right
you know if i was watching this guy get
atomized right before my eyes i would
also not try to do anything differently
than what i'm doing
because i do not want to incur the wrath
of whatever is subjecting that man to
the forces that okay that he is being
subjected
don't mind me don't move don't move
buddy don't move
don't move you don't want to move don't
move
don't move
don't move my dude don't move don't move
don't move my dude don't move okay
so far so good so far so good
and somehow this man
this dude has emerged unscathed
damn this guy is unflappable
he cannot be flapped hey what's up dude
what if i knock the rag right out of
your hands
missed missed
missed
okay you okay you got a little thing in
you
man he is this guy
never mind turns out he could die after
all
maybe i should play like this look
most your job's already taken from you
all right whatever all right whatever
it's fine
look looks in that's why i didn't i
didn't mean it i'm sorry i'm sorry it's
all good
don't worry don't get stressed all right
next area
oh amy would be so
mad at me here i go
[Music]
that's a little underwhelming is this a
butt plug what is that
it's a sticky bomb
oh no it's a sticky bomb
oh no
you'd think that this would like
continue to light on fire but apparently
not
man someone really wants the insurance
money here
all right well i'm not gonna get any joy
out of blowing pottery up
the joy the joy
the the joy i this shouldn't be joyful
this should actually be like
not joyful this should be concerning
this is a mental health test
this is a testament of someone's ability
to have empathy for others
living and or otherwise and the actions
that those actions have effect on those
people
who you are affecting anyway kumbaya
[ __ ]
oh [ __ ]
dude man oh wow last man standing
you really did it my dude
congratulations hey you know what you
get
this yeah i didn't even blow it up
you pathetic piece of poop your arm fell
off i just
fine um what about the earthquake if
everyone just like falls over
well come on do something
it's pathetic
[Music]
yeah it turns out this is just a whole
hell of a lot of damage
oh and he's dead okay well this is
pathetic
you're alive
you're dead i mean that makes more sense
but the ricochet holy [ __ ]
oh my god this should not be as
satisfying as it is
this this okay just starting to feel bad
it's starting to feel bad
the ricochets are impressive though
i gotta admit that that's very
impressive
okay well that's not exactly perfect
slow motion there that seems to be
really uh
really a shitty slow motion but
i'm being put on some watch lists
right now don't worry
it's just test dummies my dude
it's nothing to be concerned about my
bro
there's gotta be like easter eggs right
there's gotta be like easter eggs in the
other one where if you're shooting a
certain thing
in the background it'll uh it'll blow up
the entire universe probably
like what happens if we like obviously
that blows up but what happens as a
result of that there's got to be like
something else right
hmm there was like um in this uh in this
one here
in this one there was like if you
that's way too many bullets that is so
many bullets
that is so many bullets oh my god
okay wait anyway there's there's got to
be something like there's something
about the wall here i remember if you
like
if you blow the like it was creating
holes in the wall
as if there was something behind it i'm
wondering
if you keep blasting if you're gonna
penetrate through
come on give me the bottom
oh yeah this is the good stuff this is
what they call the good stuff
the good stuff exploded my eardrums
let's reset here what is in here we've
got something
okay
well it's kind of like with solar smash
not really that impressive
to be perfectly honest
i mean i know it's killing and naming
them they just kind of flop over
it's not really anything going on here
there's got to be like some interactive
interactive who's this right maybe maybe
one of these like
maybe one of these like interacts with
something in some way
that it causes something to react
explodedly there's got to be something
right it's got to be something
that's it didn't even wake the dude up
from his drunken stupor
this is pathetic this is garbo
take some of this
that's pretty cool we're not gonna lie
that not gonna lie
that's pretty cool
okay well now i'm just pulling it all
together
why did that scare me
did that scare anyone else that was like
a jump scare
i thought they were coming at me for a
revenge or something but now they just
what the hell is that what they did they
just come to the screen that's so weird
oh
god's terrifying where are they going
why are they pulling to me
all right well to be perfectly honest
i'm a little underwhelmed
unless there's like some super secret
here that i don't know about which
maybe there is because i mean you got
the black holes and everything but
what else are you gonna do what else are
you gonna do
come here you come here you come here
you come here you oh
i guess i just get to have a little bit
of fun destroying things
[Music]
it's so many bullets it's
too many bullets that's like impossible
number bullets i remember seeing
something a while back about like this
this experimental gun i don't think it
actually went anywhere but it was like a
20 by 20 grid
of like gun barrels and it
shot bullets like in a wall
and so he was just like like it would it
would shoot like 10 bullets in a row but
it would just be like a
wall of bullets and it's like at what
point
is it just too much like they're gonna
be dead whatever you hit with that thing
isn't just gonna be dead
it's gonna be like just atomized it's
like what is the point of that
they're mine it's the perfect thievery
tool
see now it's not destruction and murder
now i'm just stealing pottery i'm gonna
pull all these dudes towards me
come here you come here you this is very
weird when they just fly at the camera
okay well i guess that's kind of it um
actually you know what i could do
there's there was this knockoff this is
a knockoff of solar smash
so solar smash is popular right this is
the the shitty uh
remake version of it and apparently it
is riddled with adds
neptune why neptune what earth is what
happened to earth
what happened to mars what happened
all right let's see what up is it that
neptune
interesting all of these are locked oh
my god oh my
god oh my god
let me try the first one first
[ __ ] what is that who's this dent ass
dent in there
what is that what i didn't even hit
there
look at this freaking dented planet
where are you neptune where are you
neptune
what happened to you who did this to you
what is that
this is so pitifully stupid
it just lumpinates it oh it's gone
yeah i know i'm i'm good man i'm
yeah i'm good this looks cool okay
oh my god
[Music]
oh i'll lose my reward
[Music]
okay what did i get
what it's just a different version of
the lumpinator
it's all just lumpinations i just
lumpinize it
it's that's all lumpinations i guess
that's something
all right you know what and it's gone
neptune's gone
so this just goes to show that some uh
some knockoffs are just
not worth your time but that being said
so others are totally worth it
i think i did everything i had here bam
bang boom i'm a murderer no
no no good
god so that is all for room smash i
think i've discovered everything unless
you guys know of a secret about this
game that you can write in the comments
down below
tell me about this but pretty fun not
bad for a free game like honestly just
like solar smash it's got that kind of
like simplistic thing
where it's like a satisfying little bit
of destruction but at the same time i
just
wish there was a little bit more
happening to it because with like
with like uh solar smash is beautiful
because you can like carve art into the
thing
and this one has a few destructible
environments and i know there's got to
be like some secret interactive that i'm
not
seeing but i would love to see a little
more out of it
let me let me before i go i'm gonna i'm
gonna just try to
absolutely pound my way through this
wall
oh i know what i can do this is where it
all comes together everybody this is
where it all comes together
is so bone for chica
there she is look it's chica and there's
her tail
she's just ready and so excited because
it's the biggest bone she's ever seen
that's a good place to end this
wholesome video wholesome fun for the
whole
family thank you all so much for
watching let me know if i missed
anything
check it out for yours i'm not sponsored
by this do whatever the [ __ ] you want
anyway this isn't fun i like these
instruction games they're very cool
so thank you and as always i will see
you
in the next video bye-bye
[Music]
you